noté M pour
Mature, nous n'étions que des enfants la dernière fois, je
t'ai vu, le temps n'est pas passé pour toi
hein et j'ai Arthur dans mon oreille, je ne
lui laisse aucune chance, fais attention pendant que
tu travailles pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Nous, chez Churchill, il y avait du rhum hier soir,
c'est la boîte d'expédition de Churchill remplie
de secrets gouvernementaux et Dieu nous préserve
qu'elle tombe entre de mauvaises mains. C'est
là que nous vous contactons pour
comprendre que celui qui l'a pourrait faire sauter
le couvercle de l'Empire et déclencher une nouvelle guerre.
alors Churchill m'a demandé de veiller personnellement à ce qu'il le
récupère
[Musique]
maintenant J'ai besoin d'un soldat digne de confiance pour
aller là-bas et découvrir la vérité, allez,
allez, vous pourriez bien être cet homme, je ne suis pas
convaincu que vous
[Musique]
oui
St